oakland taking a shot at las vegas
calling our desert gross that's right
it's definitely generating a lot of
attention here the mayor libby shaft in
a weekly interview discussing the sports
and entertainment capital of the world
sports director chris matthews joining
us with more on what unfolded here chris
i'll tell you what if ever there was a
time that you could kind of sense the
oakland a's baseball project here kind
of slipping away it might be now oakland
mayor libby schaff is really desperate
to save the last two well the last pro
franchise inner city nba's warriors they
moved across the bay to san francisco of
course the raiders moved right here now
talking on a local tv outlet in san
francisco when comparing the two areas
she praised the site for the proposed
baseball uh park there the port of
oakland
which by the way they've been working on
that multi-billion dollar project for
nearly a decade while praising her own
backyard mayor schaff taking a swipe at
las vegas calling our desert gross in
her words shaft's comments lit up social
media as you would imagine of course so
let's take a look a few of those tweets
hey don't mess with our city right clark
county commissioner michael naft on
twitter mayor libby shaft this ignorant
and elitist comment may be one reason
why so many people companies and teams
want to get the heck out of your
jurisdiction i invite you to come to las
vegas anytime i'll be glad to better
inform you mayor carolyn goodman today
got wind of the comments and shot back
on social media mayor chef
has this right sustainability is a
priority the beautiful city of las vegas
is a world leader in sustainability and
top destination she writes please join
more than 42 million visitors a year and
enjoy a trip to las vegas and the best
line of course from her i think is the
last line right here where you can say
hey we can go see a raiders game even
derek carr wagging his finger this is
now home and it is best if mayor shaft
doesn't try to compare fabulous las
vegas to the east bay christian